the Republican Party
has made politics more important for
young people with the issue of abortion
this was the problem we always knew
would happen if Roe v Wade were repealed
yes it would energize some people and
they will want and try to do even more
but at the same time you can no longer
raise money to try to overturn Roe v
Wade you have to deal with the
consequences of it being gone and the
Republican strategy has always been to
present themselves as an opposition to
some kind of evil something scary
abortion through Roe v Wade mattered
when Roe v Wade was a thing so now
they're saying well let's focus on trans
anti-woke Etc but the polling isn't
looking great on that either